[Music]
okay alright five four three two one
hey everyone welcome to simulation we
have dr. Francois Bayliss in the house
hello how are you thanks for coming on
the show thanks for having me you come
from Nova Scotia
yeah the Far East Coast probably about
as far away as you can get yeah yeah
doll house ei Dalhousie Dalhousie I'm
working on it Dalhousie University 22
years there I know it's a long time eh
there you go a professor there as well
as the Canada Research Chair great
you've been working with students across
what what fields I work with any and all
students who are interested and
open-minded about the world in which we
live so I have students with a
background in medicine and healthcare I
had students in philosophy political
science anthropology sociology science
and technology studies pretty much work
with anybody yeah that's good to have
that wide breadth of fields that you get
to tap into and help well exactly I mean
I actually get to learn a lot because
they come with their own disciplinary
training which is different from mine
and I hope to sort of add something to
what they know and I get to learn from
them so it's really exciting yeah you
did your doctorate in philosophy as well
so you yourself bring a good amount of
of the questions these big questions
around these fields why are you in
political science what values do you
want to bring there what values do you
want to bring into public health so you
get asked these why questions to people
yeah I think so I think one of the
things that's really interesting for me
is that I want to encourage people to
question pretty much anything and
everything and for me a lot of that's
tied up with certain beliefs around
democracy and self-governance
and so one of the things that try to
encourage people to think about is what
does it mean to hand over to somebody
any kind of authority over how you will
get to live your life and at the same
time recognize we have to do that so
that we can in fact live together so we
have this kind of constant push and pull
between wanting to be independent live
our lives in accordance with our own
deep values and at the same time
recognizing that to live together with
others who have different values that
they probably believe in just as deeply
we need to kind of have some rules of
engagement and so it's that constant
push and pull between who we are as a
social being and who we are as a private
being on the show we were talking about
that exact thing with my extent of my
freedom ends with things like me being
able to swing my arm and accidentally
hit you because you also don't want that
to happen to yourself
so then together as a social fabric we
decide that it's better for our freedoms
to be restricted in that sense of
violence so one thing that's really
interesting for me anyhow about that
example is it's an example that we use
to explain one of the differences
between Canadians and Americans so can I
share that with you of course okay so
here's the way we think about it
this is not my work at somebody else's
so I'm just plagiarizing but it's the
suggestion that the difference is the
person who wants the freedom to play
their music as loud as they want versus
the person who wants the freedom to have
silence around them yeah and so it's
kind of like that push and pull again
and how do we figure out what kind of
freedom we're gonna you know try to
respect and support and engage
recognizing that there are reasons why
each party might feel that way about the
exercise of their freedom the public
transit system
their music system the public trances
them and then there's so you usually see
this maybe older Asian man or woman
that's just sitting there kind of you
can't tell if they're meditating or
sleeping on the bus but there's uh
there's moments of in this also visible
in the parks you're in the park there's
people that are very very loud in the
park there's people that are very quiet
in the park and that's this is that's a
very good example but not not the
violent examples but the audio examples
I like that right yeah because I wonder
and I will let's stay on this just for a
second because I think it's actually
really interesting to share so where
would an ideal civilization have that
that audio level of okay I'm now in a
park there's a bunch of other people in
the park and how loud can I be without
distract without disturbing other people
that want to be silent where do you
where do you think an ideal world would
look like in that what's the thing I
think is interesting is I think that
there can be many right answers to that
question
and for me what becomes interesting is
are you willing to explore a number of
right answers yeah are you willing to
talk to other people and see what you
can negotiate maybe what you negotiate
is the volume maybe what you negotiate
is the time so I get to have it as loud
as I want but maybe only the during this
time and you get to have complete
silence at another time or maybe we say
no we'll just put the volume here and I
get to have it all the time but not at
the ideal volume for you know my wishes
or whatever you know I think there's
just lots of ways that's good that you
could come up with solutions what's
important is that you're willing to work
towards a solution as opposed to you're
gonna stand up say this is my right and
I worry about those kinds of
conversations in any domain right and
and partly I worry about them because I
say well who gave you that right you
just get to assert it you know and and
how do you get to then sort of say to
the rest of the world that they ought to
respect that right meanwhile you don't
respect theirs yeah exactly and I think
the the interesting thing is to start by
recognizing that we have many interests
in common that we share this planet writ
large and then
when I start wearing about you know
overpopulation environmental issues
pollution nuclear war I mean all of
those things they all affect us in our
daily lives whether we recognize it or
not right and there's sort of that big
picture thing that we need to think
about and then there's just everything
that happens that little microcosm the
bet you know showing respect for the
people you live with showing respect to
the people you work with showing respect
for people who go to places that you
don't visit you know but that you know
is important for them so what does it
mean to be respectful of difference I
think we have a long way to go still on
that one yeah I'm sure we could stay
here for a while and talk about this and
I think maybe we should stay a little
bit longer this kind of takes me to a
lot of the thought he touched on this as
you were getting into it but of
individualism but also collectivism hmm
we are a little far away from figuring
out the right balance between those two
and I wonder what I'll ideally look like
especially for raising kids into the
world that you teach them hey go
self-actualize find all these cool
things that you want to do that you want
to bring value into the world but also
we're building a better social fabric to
help foster you and your actualization
but also to foster your fellow sisters
and brothers and their actualization as
well right so for me that you know where
that resonates is I've done a lot of
work on the concept of identity and I've
done that in the context of a number of
different kinds of health care issues or
interventions so I first looked at the
question of identity around race and
that was in the early days when this
sort of ancestry tracing stuff was just
starting out and nobody kind of knew
where it was gonna go and there wasn't a
lot of competition but you know people
were starting to say we'd be able to
find out who they really were by tracing
our DNA so that made me think well what
does it mean
who you really are and that you need to
check your genetics to figure that out
and then I started thinking about
identity in the context of face
transplantation and again that was
before anybody had done a single face
transplantation and I asked myself well
what would it be like to look in the
mirror and to see a different face from
the one you had
you know however long you've had that
particular face and this isn't about
aesthetics or anything else it's just
like what does it mean to look and to
see something that's different I then
looked at identity in the context of
deep brain stimulation what does it mean
to consent to you know having somebody
mess with your brain in some way shape
or form and so getting back to your
comment you know when you think about
self-actualization and I bring to that
sort of my reflections on identity I'm
thinking about well what do I say back
to people who have this idea that
there's this true authentic self that
they have to find and they have to
protect and I actually call that into
question and I think that what's really
important about identity is recognizing
that it's constantly in flux and so what
that does is it gives permission to see
yourself as constantly evolving
constantly learning and the true you is
the you in that moment with everything
that happened before because that
determines how you're going to behave in
this moment everything is somewhere in
there in that trajectory so for me
self-actualization is what you do all
the time just by living just by living
that's what you're doing and when I say
that I have to allow that that's not a
claim about what's good or bad because
we can have identities that are actually
unhealthy so it's not a claim about a
good identity or a bad identity it's
just a claim a description about how we
live and navigate in the world so a bit
of a complicated answer to what you
probably thought was the string oh that
that was actually very interesting and
thank you all for that one self identity
awareness so
so if everything that I do is bringing
me towards self-actualization and then
there's all of these potential changes
that could be made along the way which
we're going to talk about but even
something as crazy as a face transplant
or as a change in my genetics or a
change in my neurology through brain
stimulation gender change and gender
that's happening let's forget bender
that it stays as me I stay as myself or
I'm changing where does my identity fit
into that well I don't believe that
identity is static and I think that's
what I was meeting when I said there is
no authentic true self I think there is
just you constantly living and
recognizing that your self is dynamic
and if you have permission to think of
yourself that way what it allows you to
think about are the ways in which you
try on personas and you play out certain
things at certain times I believe that
we have both preferred and projected
identities and they don't always map so
I want you to see me as something I want
you to see me as an attractive
intelligent woman and I'm gonna behave
in a certain kind of way trying to get
you to see that and if I'm successful
you're gonna behave back towards me in a
way that's gonna reinforce that sense of
self and I'll be confident in the way
that I'm projecting etc but imagine that
that's not what you see so you respond
to me as this like who is this idiot
sitting across from me and like oh my
gosh I've got to sit and talk to her for
how long well I'm gonna get those vibes
and I'm gonna say okay he's not reading
me well I better change the way I'm
behaving I better try to better
communicate Who I am or who I want you
to see and I think that in that context
often we're actually hiding things
because there's things about ourselves
that we don't want to project or there's
things about ourself that we think
that's not gonna get me the feedback
that I want or there are things that I
repress because society tells me those
things are not acceptable
and so there are lots of ways I think in
which we are constantly subconsciously
doing that so you know I'm not crazy I
don't think everybody sitting here
thinking how am I gonna behave where do
I put my hand what we don't do that so
consciously but something yes exactly
subconsciously we're constantly doing
that because we're looking for
affirmation right
we are deeply social beings we are
relational beings other people want to
tell us that we're just intellectual
rational beings but we're not we know
that we're emotive in addition to
rational and I think that what grounds
all of that is our relation ality we are
relational beings and so we are
constantly looking for ways in which we
can fit in and belong even if you choose
to sort of behave in ways that you know
are going to be brusque or upsetting to
others that's because that's how you
want to play it sometimes and sometimes
you don't want to play it that way you
didn't realize you did that and people
respond in a way and then you kind of
get to try it again and I believe that
if you're not able to do that well -
what if two things happens you blow out
so you leave you have to change your
community of belonging because you're
not belonging and I think belonging is
really important
and so you blow out or the other thing
is I honestly believe that that's when
you're at risk of mental illness and I
say that in the sense of I want to
belong and I'm doing everything I can
that I know how to do to belong and it's
still not working for me and I've
changed communities I've done all the
kinds of things and it's still not
working so people can't read me and I'm
projecting as best as I can I'm telling
you who I am and I'm just meeting with
either misunderstanding or rejection or
whatever that's pretty lonely confusing
place to be right so the self is dynamic
it's always changing and then there's a
layer of subconscious that we don't
usually come that doesn't usually boil
up to the top of our minds as we
converse that is that we're aware of
that alters the way that we actually
converse with people to try and get
things to happen in our favor I want to
be portrayed as somebody that is
confident that knows what they're
talking about and other people to see
that that's why I don't just randomly go
like hobbsy code
and then you're like would it heated
what was that like I don't know if I
should keep talking to him or not
so so there's things like that or or
even or even like you were saying
earlier this happens all the time for
sex for sex happens all the time I mean
of subconsciously worth it I didn't say
that you said sexy attractive yes so so
it totally happens for sex all the time
subconsciously all the time and so that
dynamic self that's constantly changing
constantly tweaking itself ends up
becoming the self or whatever that that
is as you grow along the way yes oh let
me add another sort of layer to it
because we're relational beings I think
one of the things that we are sometimes
more or less aware of and it can change
constantly is the way in which we're
affected by all the people around us who
give us permission to either be a
particular way or not and so one of the
analogies that I sometimes use is I
think a little Co correctness culture
right now
well preventing a lot of people from
being able to say certain things well
that's a whole other topic which should
come back to in a minute but where I
wanted to go with that is I think that
um I invite people to think about living
their life as though you're in a play
and you're going to be in a play no well
I've I've often said that this is an
improv this is really life in itself as
an improv on a daily basis you're acting
you're the performer life's a stage and
we're all in the cast all those clichés
are true and I say that I do never see
the thing that's really interesting
about the play is that people then know
that there are other actors there's a
director there's an audience and all of
them have an influence on how you get to
be your persona right and one of the
things that's really interesting is that
when you go into that play you typically
got a role and what becomes frustrating
is when you don't get to play
[Applause]
it's just because you wanted to come and
participate but you see imagine if your
role is to be the comedian and one day
you're just really sad and so when you
come out on stage you don't play the
role you're supposed to play and
everybody's kind of freaking out around
here like what's going on like they're
supposed to be the comedian here they're
being really sad and I don't know how to
work with that etc and one of the things
that can happen is people can either
just keep playing as if you're the
comedian and kind of like not deal with
the reality of what's going on or they
have to actually change and shift and
amend and say okay we're going off
script here all right and so I think one
of the things that's really interesting
is when do we have permission to just be
who we are and when are we constantly
playing a role to keep everybody else
happy right who are we
that's really good what is it it happens
it happens a lot to everyone were the
social influences that come on to our
being constantly tweak our behavior in
ways that we don't know if we are
actually being who we really are or for
being someone else subconsciously that
we are now being affected by our
environment to be that so so this is
this is a man we we we went into it a
cool first first segue of topic I like
it I like this one and I think it's it
plays a very deep role in society that
we don't often question or talk about
because I think in and I could it be
possible that in an ideal world you get
to be yourself all the time
without social pressures changing and
forming you into you see I don't think
there is a self accept in this kind of
social construct right I mean I don't
know what it would be to have if you're
born into a white box without any other
people yeah I mean if you want truly
like a real hermit like how would you be
in a world I don't know because so much
of how I understand myself is a function
of the pea
that I've met and the way in which I've
interacted with them and they have
marked me you know and they may have
marked me positively or negatively but I
carry traces of that with me all the
time and you know it may or may not
surface but I might behave one day in a
way because of something that happened
that I have subconsciously registered
that tells me oh this would be behavior
I'm comfortable with right now or maybe
it's not behavior I'm comfortable with
its behavior that's gonna put other
people around me in kind of a comfort
zone I want that right now I want them
to feel comfortable so I'll do this that
may not be comfortable for me but that
I've kind of gauged would be for them so
like I said I don't think of all these
kind of exchanges as sort of conscious I
just think that we are relational
embodied beings people read stuff off of
bodies all the time and people behave in
ways that they're looking for
affirmation of a particular kind at all
times in some way shape or form
sociology is fascinating and so is the
subconscious how it's baked into
sociology how these inter-relational
processes amongst this massive system of
economic and political being coexist and
vibe with each other I'm very fascinated
by that I'm glad that we started with
that and there's a whole episode on that
so let's let's get into a couple
different applicable other topics along
the way we'll probably touch on that as
we go sure
so okay so with being a part of the
Faculty of Medicine
there's especially with obstetrics and
gynaecology so a lot of this is with
reproductive health with women's health
and with childbirth yes yes so teach us
about what you've been learning about
this why it's important for men
especially to care about this and women
both
so I actually talk about a whole range
of issues in the area of reproduction
and a lot recently as you might imagine
is around assisted reproductive
technologies largely because those
technologies impact women typically more
so than men that's not to say that men
are not impacted as well but if we're
just talking about the bodies
bodies of women are affected differently
I think in terms of that reproductive
process so I talk a lot about that but I
also talk about other topics and
reproductive choice so for example
termination of pregnancy as you can
imagine controversial issue for all
kinds of reasons but when I talk about
that I don't only talk about issues like
the moral status of the developing human
embryo or fetus which everybody's kind
of aware of but then I'll talk about the
ethics of access which is the different
kind of topic those are two completely
contrasting the the death of the fetus
versus the ethics of the availability of
an abortion in the first place yes
exactly and so you know I'll talk about
that but then I also will go into
domains that are not as popular and by
popular here I just mean they're not as
current people are not sort of focused
on them and so one of those topics that
I talk about and teach about is the
obligation okay and I'm actually using
that word purposely the obligation to
include pregnant women in clinical
trials and most people look at me and
say what like that's not what you want
to do clinical trials or risky
activities and we don't want to put
pregnant women into clinical trials
their follow-up is why well exactly so
what I try to do is to explain that if
you don't do that then the only
treatments you can ever offer to
pregnant women are off-label treatments
and so I argue that you are actually
doing something really wrong to pregnant
women you're saying to pregnant women
I'm never gonna learn about any
healthcare problem you might have while
you're pregnant and so if you know when
it comes to me and you say oh you know
but I'm a brittle diabetic and I'm
pregnant or oh I'm depressed and I'm
pregnant oh I have Crohn's disease and
I'm pregnant I go oh well we never
studied that pregnant women so because
we're pregnant women in clinical trials
well that's what happens we keep them
out of clinical trials and what you need
to understand is this can be some fixed
prior to pregnancy there are certain
aspects of it that we can work on prior
to pregnancy so that we don't have to
try and fix it as we get pregnant all
kinds of times right and it's not always
intentional and purposeful and it's not
as if you say okay well I'm gonna fix my
Crohn's and then I'm gonna go get
pregnant
and and even so I mean a lot of these
kinds of conditions are chronic and so
it's not something that you can just
kind of you know deal with and then move
on with a healthy pregnancy you know the
phrase I trying to use as I say look
sick women get pregnant and pregnant
women get sick right so you can start a
pregnancy completely healthy and
something goes off the rails and my
point is that if you think it's a really
good thing that I should do research in
white men so that I can give them access
to therapies why isn't it a good thing
to do research in pregnant women so that
I can give them access to good therapies
and some of those good therapies are
about protecting them in the fetus the
one thing that comes to mind is that yes
there's so much about protecting the
woman and protecting the fetus but at
the same time there is the potential
harm that it could cause the fetus
because it's a clinical trial we're just
testing things out and figuring it out
okay but if we should still play and
figure it out totally but my point is
we're playing and figuring it out no
matter what the only difference is we're
not calling at a clinical trial because
if I'm your doctor and you come to me
and you say I'm pregnant and I have this
health condition or you don't know what
your health condition is but I figure it
out as your physician then I say okay we
don't actually know what to do so let's
try this or I say I don't know what to
do but you can go talk to you know
doctor so-and-so down the hall and
they're probably gonna do this well
they're doing that on the basis of what
maybe past experience maybe trials and
animal models maybe trials in you know
unpregnant women but the bottom line is
they're still guessing so we're gonna
call that treatment even though they're
guessing it's research it's just not
formalized as a clinical trial which
also means we're not actually gonna
getting data that we can then use and
collate and put together and actually
get knowledge so what I try to do is I
get people to think about why do you
think it's safe just because it's not
happening in a clinical trial if it's
actually happening without the
background of data coming from a
clinical trial or the background of data
coming from you know some kind of
context may not be a clinical trial why
do you think that's safer I'm saying
it's just as risky and the only
difference is if it's happening in a
proper clinical trial over time we're
actually getting knowledge that can
benefit of community and that's what
research is about research is about
benefiting a community anybody who goes
into a clinical trial is taking on risks
for the community that's a good way to
put it is that where women get sick when
they're pregnant and they also get
pregnant when they're sick and so
there's a whole intense the important
body of research that needs to be
conducted around women and pregnancies
and public health around that time for
them for the fetus for the ethics of
having availability for all the
different diseases that are happening
within a woman's health while they're
going through this process just their
health in general so this is very
important to test and figure out so so
what is what's the best way to get us
into into clinical trials with women
that are pregnant and what things should
be at the forefront of figuring out the
testing so the interesting thing for me
is I would ask women what are the kinds
of things that are really important for
you to know about in terms of knowing
your body and having a positive impact
on your pregnancy so maybe women say you
know I'm interested in probiotics I want
to know is that a good thing for me to
take or not take etc so I think that's
the first thing you could think about
actually consulting the group of
potential future research participants
and what are questions about what you
would like to have answers I think
that's one kind of approach another kind
of approach seems to be a good one to
touch to figure out sure and I think
another kind of approach would sort of
say where is it that we don't have any
knowledge such that you actually would
see it as self-interested for yourself
for the fetus for a future pregnancy for
us to get knowledge and I can imagine a
number of scenarios where if you're
presented the option to a woman that
said look we know nothing about this
condition here's the option you can just
knock on any one of these doors of any
one of these doctors and they'll give
you whatever they think is best
now they'll truly be trying to do what's
best for you but they're gonna be
guessing or you can come into my
clinical trial I'll be guessing too but
at the end of this process
we'll have knowledge
in fact when I'm guessing you might be
getting in my clinical trial the very
same thing you'd have gotten from some
doctor down the hall because nobody
actually has good knowledge right
because that's the only context in which
we do research right research is about
asking a question to which we don't know
the answer we know the answer then we're
not really doing research might be doing
something else but we're not doing
research we might be doing marketing and
so I think there's lots of ways of
figuring out what's a good question but
my point is I just want to say the
starting assumption which is that we
keep pregnant women out of clinical
trials because it's going to help the
fetus it's not a good starting
assumption if you don't know what you're
doing you could be harming the fetus so
it's time to do some research and for
clinical trials with pregnant women okay
yeah that I think got me interested in
that topic is we have typically done
clinical trials in pregnant women only
when we think it's about helping the
fetus not when we think it's not helping
a pregnant woman yeah and the classic
example that people use to make that
point is HIV lots of people interested
in doing research and pregnant women
when what they were concerned about with
what we refer to as vertical
transmission from the pregnant woman to
the fetus how can we help the fetus then
all kinds of people happy to enroll
pregnant women in a clinical trial yeah
but what if you know it's just about
women and their own health
you're not filtered through the needs or
the benefits of a particular pregnancy
this so interesting so that seems to be
the number one thing you brought it up
is the first thing is getting women and
more public health attention on
pregnancy and on women and pregnancy
what are other aspects of the research
that you think is really important to
vocalize and get more people I think
there's lots of areas of women's health
that are neglected in terms of what I
would describe as a knowledge production
and so a really good example of that
which connects up with another area of
my work which is assisted reproduction
say one thing first it's not it is crazy
that a woman basically has a human being
grow inside of her isn't that amazing
isn't it spectacular
delivers the human being and that's
spectacular yes Ron we see you over
there it's wonderful that's wonderful it
is it's so much different than the than
the egg the egg used to have all the
nutrients inside of it for the for the
for the beam to birth from the egg the
reptile from the ocean onto the land
that would then have the egg now it's
inside of us but you see that's one of
the things that's changed right in the
last 40 years with assisted reproductive
technologies we have the embryo outside
of the human body and that's crazy now
well I mean how does it get the right
nutrients how does the heart and the
brain develop differently than if it was
inside well job asking those questions
they're Punk well especially once it's
outside of the body we forget that it
has to get back into a woman's body in
order at least right now in order for it
to develop into one of us when does when
does it have to go back in well
typically it'll be put back into a
woman's body at around a five so days
zero the sperm and egg meet yes and then
day five well you can put the embryo
back in before that but very often what
will happen is it you'll allow the
embryo to continue to develop so the
cells will divide in what's called a
petri dish yep and the reason for that
is that you'll be able to observe things
like what's its nutrient uptake
what is it excreting are the cells nice
and round so they'll look at the
morphology of the developing embryo and
on that basis there will be sometimes a
selection right so if you have lots of
embryos you might say these are the best
ones to put back in in the hope of
initiating a pregnancy these are ones
that we might discard these are ones we
might donate to research these are ones
we might freeze so there's lots of
decision making what happens when the
embryo is outside of the ball
but one of the areas in which we can
kind of connect up these two
conversations is now we have number of
times when people are looking to create
families where they need access to what
we refer to as donor Danny so let's take
the example of donor eggs so if you have
a heterosexual couple and for whatever
reason the woman doesn't have any eggs
you need to go get eggs or you have a
heterosexual couple and there's a
problem with that genetic material you
need to go get donor eggs or you have a
homosexual couple and they don't have
eggs between them and they need to go
get eggs so there's lots of kinds of
scenarios in which people want access to
reproductive material so one of the
things that's fascinating is there are
egg donors and many of them are saying
why aren't you doing research on us so
that we can fully understand the
potential harms of being an egg donor so
that we can actually make an informed
consent right so one of the things that
I find fascinating is we're not doing
that research and yet we're asking women
to undertake what we know to be are
certain kinds of risks because people
have experienced them right and yet we
don't do systematic research in order to
just say back to women look if you want
to be an egg donor these are the
benefits and these are the harms and yet
in the abstract that's what we think we
ought to do right people ought to be
able to make informed choices about
whatever they want to do with their
bodies and yet we don't go get that
information so the people can make good
choices the amount of instances that are
that require reproductive materials is
actually very high and it seems to be a
lot of people don't really realize how
often sperm because their eggs are
needed and how many different couple
variations there are that require a
productive materials I'm so fascinated
by this embryo that is in a petri dish
for a couple days and then put back into
the woman
it's divided and then there's there's
some for freezing some for research some
for oh my goodness what happens to the
embryo food goes past five days like in
a month is it dead because it's not
inside of a human so right now there is
actually kind of an international
agreement that we don't keep human
embryos outside the body for more than
14 days now that agreement if you will
this it's it's formalized in a couple of
countries so there are countries that
with actual legislation that says you
cannot keep a human embryo outside the
body beyond 14 days there are other
places where they don't have that
legislation but it's kind of like I said
an international agreement that we don't
go beyond 14 days what's interesting is
that it's only in the past year or so
that people are actively calling into
question and saying why don't we agree
to that and saying you know what we want
to go beyond 14 days now now we yes
absolutely for research but what's
interesting is the history of that so in
the early days when they said you can't
go beyond 14 days it's actually based in
ethical arguments that they tried to
hang on biology so the argument was
along these lines up until that point
you can have a phone and call 20 and
recombination so what that means
twinning is that you've got an egg and a
sperm and they've come together made an
embryo and up until 14 days there's this
phenomenon called twinning that can
happen which means it actually splits
and that's how you get identical twins
there's the reverse which is called
recombination so you're gonna sperm and
egg in a sperm they both made two
different embryos and inside the body
they can recombine and make a mosaic
that can either of those things can't
happen after 14 days and they said you
know what that means 14 days must be
really important 40 days is really
important so you can't do anything up
until 14 days elsewhere people were
saying in terms of the science what
happens is that on day 15 you get
something called the primitive streak
which is the precursor to the brain and
people say you know what's really
important with humans its birth great
big brain when these are action
and so day 15 must be really important
so we're gonna pick 14 to be on the safe
side okay you know I've kind of
embellished the story a little bit but
it's just to make the point that they
use biology to try and come up with this
really clear demarcation line day 14 and
from my perspective what happened back
then is people said okay it's really
controversial that you would do research
on human embryos and you have these
embryos outside of the body but as long
as it'll go past day 14 you're okay and
the science association I can sign yeah
sure I can do that no problem easy to
agree to that deadline I didn't know how
to keep them beyond 14 days anyway so
that's like saying okay bailiffs you
can't go to Mars
like what do I care I can't go to Mars
everything I can but what if I can't or
they don't think oh why did I ever agree
that I can't go to Mars you know and I
think that's what we're starting to see
yeah with the science because we
actually have groups of scientists that
say I think I can do this I can take it
beyond 14 days and they're saying look
if you really want me to solve cancer
you gotta give me more than 14 days I
need I need more time I need to have
that embryo it's not of the body I need
to understand how that cellular division
is taking place because it's the reverse
that's happening with cancer so let me
better understand that and look at that
I'll be able to help you solve cancer I
mean again I'm excited for what happens
after the 14 day mark you know it also
feels a little bit weird because I also
feel weird about the brain and the heart
starting to develop and then just a
bunch of humans like poking and prodding
it trying to figure it out but the
interesting thing is that what we have
right now and this is just the real
world we have scientists working at both
ends if you will up the life spectrum
meaning you have scientists working on
some of the challenges at the level of
reproduction we have scientists working
on longevity and the fact that we're
dying off sooner than they think we need
to and then if you actually just bring
it back to reproduction we've got people
that are working on artificial wounds
and you know certain kinds of fancy
incubator type things so that they'll be
able to go backwards in time and then
you have people over here working with
the developing embryo in the petri dish
trying to come forward in time and so
you know what happens if ever and it may
not happen in my lifetime but if you've
got people working on in a project what
what happens if you truly could have
that whole gestation happening outside
the body that's so interesting the the
gestation this loops us to the initial
like fascination of the woman being the
incubator for the child but I worry
about that language because I think that
that helps us to think of the woman as a
vessel and the woman's not a vessel
she's not a container I mean and I kind
of you know I have people say things
like oh yeah you got a bun in the oven
I'm saying she's not and she's not
cooking a bun okay I mean that's what so
a human being is in fact growing inside
of her right but it's not a separate
entity again if it can just state
outside of a woman that's all
fascinating let's explore that let's
figure that out because it might
actually be better for the woman's
health potentially to just stayed
outside I don't know I mean I don't know
I don't know if it's better for women's
health or for the fetus's health because
one of the things that's really
important about ourselves that we negate
all the time is gene environment
interaction and so I actually think
something really important happens when
you are just dating affairs for yourself
and for the fetus well there's certainly
a lot of people doing research on the
science and that I know this stuff
versus if it's just stating like in a
close quiet environment it's not getting
sunlight it's not getting a fresh air
their sight but it isn't just that I
mean you know there's things that you're
consuming environment in which you're
moving there's all kinds of stuff that's
happening that we don't even understand
and so I sometimes think you know on the
one hand I kind of believe that you know
what anything can happen
and another part of me thinks what
happened to all right like I remember it
was explained when you would be like in
awe of something that we accomplished
and I think the last time I truly I
remember seeing that around me was you
know a human being walked on the moon
and like everybody was in awe and the
world stopped like told watch this event
kind of thing and then it's like oh yeah
we can do that Marty I sure will go
there one day and like look wait a sec
what happened to all right and so a lot
going her pace
their lives right now there's a lot of
there's a lot of purpose or a lack of
humility yeah probably some both there's
there's there's too much economic
flourishing and too little meaning and
purpose that it's now more more
difficult for people to find joy because
of that lack of purpose or meaning or
humility that whole process and the lack
of inspiration to want to create
something of joy or purpose but there's
there's so much more there there's
there's this I had this realization that
you know the idea that once the thymus
vehicles are all over the streets that
there there will be someone that's still
like I want to drive the car like your
gestation gets the point where it's so
expensive for you to drive your car
because by that point the data will be
and the safest thing to be in it's a
driverless car and so your premiums are
gonna go through the roof because you're
now a danger right and that same thing
for female gestation that it that your
premiums will go up if you're like no I
want to house the child it's like no
there's actually a lot more health risks
if you do let's do it like everyone else
is doing but you see the interesting
thing is going to become how are we
gonna understand health and what's going
to come out as a risk and I think with
reproduction one of the things I worry
about is the ways in which we're coming
up with assumptions about what a healthy
perfect baby is and we've already seen
that certainly in my lifetime with the
introduction of all kinds of prenatal
testing we now have different ideas
about what it means to have a healthy
baby
and I think we really ought to question
some of the ways in which you've kind of
been carried along by technology rather
than directing the technology and I
think a lot of people would never using
a lot of concerns you know about that I
mean one of the things I teach in
obstetrics and gynecology is I ask the
question are there better and worst
reasons for a woman to want to have a
termination of pregnancy you know I get
answers all over the spectrum and people
will say well you know if this is a
young woman exactly
and they typically go for the young
woman you know twelve years old been
raped and they've got a lot of sympathy
there and then you give them another
kind of scenario and then hey me have
less sympathy well one of the ones that
I forced people to have a conversation
about is a woman who comes forward and
says the babies of the wrong sex is that
a good enough reason and I want people
to think about you know is your
difference between having no reasons or
mild policy in China well but I mean the
reality of it is we have a lot of people
but we have a lot of people that really
want to have a baby of a particular sex
and one of the things that I say back is
you know what that's actually a
misdescription it's not that you want to
be any of a particular sex you want a
baby of a particular gender why because
parents aren't sitting there saying you
know I like this kind of genitalia
that's the kind of baby I want what
they're imagining is the way in which
then baby is gonna grow up to be a child
and an adult in the world and they have
preconceived ideas about what's
appropriate behavior and so they're
trying to have a child that's gonna fit
that preconceived sense of who they want
their child to be now I deeply worry
about that so I say you're not you're
not picking genitalia you're picking a
gender role and there's something really
deeply problematic about that no other
people turn around and say oh no no no
Francois do you think that you know
we're just gonna pick you know boys and
that you're worried about that kind of
you know gender bias I'm saying no I'm
worried about the fact that you try to
cleanse what you're doing by calling it
family balancing and then turning around
and saying no no no Francois I already
have two boys I really want a girl and
so it's not about you know the wrong
kind of gender bias and it's a failure
to understand that what's at stake is
trying to close down the future of some
child who you don't know how they're
gonna be in the world but you're
bringing to that child a whole set of
assumptions about what's appropriate
behavior you're looking at me personally
like I just said something really
strange it's also interesting it's so
difficult to actually be able to nail
down a time when it's like what is
appropriate for changing the gender of
your child and
we talked about this before but you know
how does a parent know that their
two-year-old is supposed to be a boy
instead of a girl how do they do they
change the sex of the child what does
that do does the child maybe grow out of
that feeling or that process this is all
these complicated questions and then do
you terminate the pregnancy because it's
a certain gender I mean this is it's
been had it's just there's been crazy
historical impact that this has had with
what went on with the one-child policy
in China to prevent it about 400 million
births in thirty five or so years and
that is a you were talking about
overpopulation earlier it seems like
we're going towards a period of actually
population stabilization once Africa and
other places on the planet that are
still in the process of developing
become developed nations then a
replacement fertility rates are about
equal and then we don't have the issue
of overpopulation becoming something
that we have to really be concerned
about so could that end up being a could
is reproductive health something that's
crucially important is is is identifying
the gender of the child at a young age
and being able to tweak it through or
terminate it is that is this these are
very interesting questions that's that's
our 15 minute timer thank you Ron
hua there's a we're running out of time
I know it feels like we've only
scratched the surface we're gonna get to
have topics I want to talk about you
know let's let's talk let's see if we
can go through some of them fairly
quickly one that I think we should talk
about on the way and we'll get to like
science communication and we'll get to
some of that on the way there in terms
of in terms of wealth inequality and
globalization we talked about this on
the show a lot there's been a lot of
concentration of wealth and
[Music]
and there's slope there's different
ethics across different countries for
genetic engineering and for human
augmentation where do you think we're
gonna go with all this so I am on the
side of people who worry deeply about
the widening gap between the haves and
have-nots so I worry about what's
happening between the 1% and the 99% and
I actually am very concerned about the
fact that I think we're moving towards
the situation whereby wealthy powerful
elites are going to be able to entrench
their privilege in their DNA because
they're gonna be the people that have
access to this technology and they will
control the access to that technology
and they will further instantiate their
privilege in the world and I I don't
understand why we don't see that that's
a really big problem and I'm not just
saying you know all these examples in
terms of films and novels telling us
about you know various kinds of
dystopias but there's a part of it it
just wants to say you know even today if
we just look at the issue of wealth
without even you know overlaying it with
the genetics it's like this is like Mary
Antoinette and let them eat cake do you
really think that you can just spend
your life saying to the bulk of the
world let them eat cake
well you're busy sort of living off the
riches of what I'm really worried about
what we've seen happening and I probably
worry about it because I do have
children and I recognize that the world
they're inheriting it's not the world
that I inherited and I don't think that
we've made it better for them that
doesn't mean that we haven't got more
interesting toys and more challenging
things the world is very different in
terms of Technology in terms of certain
kinds of opportunities etc but really I
think that's for a certain cadre of
society that things are exciting and
their possibilities but I teach at a
university and I see a host of mental
health issues amongst our young I see
young people who are talented and they
are worried about whether they'll ever
get a job and I can tell you that when I
was
age I knew that if I worked hard I would
get a job and I would get an interesting
job because there were great interesting
jobs out there nowadays you see young
people who understand that they're
probably gonna have precarious labor for
their lifetime you see young people that
don't believe they're gonna do better
than their parents whereas my generation
certainly thought we would and most of
us did and I think you're going to see
young people who I'll get a get angry
it's like you know we've wrecked things
mmm and we seem to continue living our
lives the way we want with whatever we
can you know reap from this world
thinking well you know we're not gonna
inherit the myth somebody else will and
they'll fix it you know I think I have a
real problem with the way we're living
our lives right now without the kind of
attention that we need in if we can
bring it back to an earlier conversation
we're having about rights we're very
good at cleaning all rights we're not so
good at cleaning our obligations you
know huge obligations that we're just
kind of turning a blind eye to we have
obligation to make the world a better
place to enrich humanity through our
lives and to provide a better world for
the children of tomorrow and their
children and onward we have a huge
obligation to do that every human does
and also I'm happy that you are so aware
of what's going on in your you you know
I'm in the process of writing a book
about it I think it's that important to
talk about and we'll see what we end up
doing with it I think the more people
that voice we can do a whole episode on
what is on what why are people not more
concerned about rampant technology
across the front industries exacerbating
wealth inequality and and what's gonna
happen muscaria is an authoritarian
state the best case scenario is everyone
gets uplifted together through this
technology but I actually think the
worst thing is not going to be an
authoritarian state I think the worst
thing is a certain kind of complacency
where we are going to believe that we
are making independent
decisions without a good understanding
of the ways in which we've been
socialized to believe that and so we're
gonna take on values that tell us that
you know this is the kind of decision we
should be making and we're going to
assert with confidence that we made an
autonomous choice
without really understanding how we've
been socialized even worse you you're
slaving you don't know you're a slave
even [ __ ] worse yeah well I think
that that's exactly the thing that we
ought to be thinking about and worrying
about yeah you know when a person if we
go back to reproductive technologies in
the person uses a technology like a
prenatal diagnosis to understand
something about the health of the
developing fetus or they use
pre-implantation genetic diagnosis to
look at the health of the embryo or one
day they use CRISPR technology to create
their version of the healthy embryo what
I want you to think about is what went
into your thoughts about what would be a
healthy embryo what made you think that
you know for example a child with Down
syndrome is an imperfect child and
imperfect fetus and imperfect embryo
right we have those beliefs because
through technology we've had certain
kinds of abilities to make certain kinds
of decisions and we've been socialized
into believing that this is what a good
mother does or this is what a good
couple does or this is you know but
those are all creations right those are
all us coming up with ideas we've built
a world that thrives on capitalism which
is then based on the premise of AI
innovate I make this technology and the
people that can contribute monetarily to
it will get the service and that leaves
behind other people that can't
contribute to the service monetarily and
that money can then go into further
research and development of it it can
maybe decrease the costs of it and
therefore make it more readily available
to middle class and lower class people
that seems to be the best case system
that we currently have manifested not
maybe we make a lottery of some sort
where one out of every couple of these
procedures gets goes to a low-income
person there's so many different ways to
approach and look at it
you know what's interesting is we're
coming full circle to something that we
kept touching upon the way which is the
issue of capitalism you know the thing
that I find interesting is how many of
our contemporary problems I think were
rated in capitalism and an example of
that materialism conspicuous consumption
exactly and when you think about that
one of the things that's happening now
is we are moving to a world where we
encourage people to put the body in the
marketplace right so we'll sell our
blood will sell our sperm also our eggs
proposals now for selling you know
kidneys because it's a parrot organ
etcetera and what happens when you you
kind of just go down that route and
there's nothing left in the world that
you think must be out of the marketplace
right I would have thought that I would
have agreement that know the human body
at the very least you don't put that in
the marketplace
be prostituted maybe that's our sex
worker maybe people want to do sex work
that's something that they're actually
interested but I think there's a funny
lack of money then they put their body
up on the market there's well you know I
think that you know women can't you know
competently autonomous my chance to do
sex work I think by actually seeing
difference between them and really
putting your bits and pieces into the
marketplace because you have nothing
else what's off the limits was your
question exactly I like that question
and I think that for me at the very
least it ought to be the bits and pieces
right miss you shouldn't be selling off
our body bits I I don't think we should
be selling off our body bits or
encouraging an economy that works on
that yeah yeah that's that's a that's a
really good question Francois what
should be off-limits and what should we
teach kids is off limits definitely
things like like teaching kids to murder
other people or harvesting their
attention for money and for cliques and
stuff like that is so every time I come
to the states I'm always struck by you
know the tolerance for violence in this
country and one of the things that I
think is interesting is the ways in
which this particular country seems
unable to deal with that how do you how
do you have tolerance for the
level of violence against each other I
think as the economy thrives and the gap
between the haves and the have-nots
increases there's more social
psychological biological anxiety
depression all these issues that occur
and then that creates a lot of turmoil
between the haves and the have-nots even
in the have-nots there's a lot of
violence and aggression between the
haves there is violence and aggression
the the the thriving economy also causes
people to turn towards each other and
say there's so many examples but oh you
have this I don't have it therefore I
envy there's there's so much and and
isn't it coveting coveting who knows if
that who knows if that envy is even good
if that person has started a charity or
philanthropy that is impacting some
place in the world and you have Envy
about that that might be good envy cuz
you want to start and make some impact
in that sense but if they have six
yachts and you're sitting there going I
can't believe they have six yards I want
three at least then that creates a
massive culture of materialism and of
conspicuous consumption so this is
another whole episode as well and I'm
really happy that you're you care about
this topic as well you're losing your
opinions to the world I don't think we
can ignore that today is the day that
they have this famous royal wedding
right and the thing that strikes me is
how much money was spent on that right
whether you're talking about the
champagne secure sausage rolls the
wedding dress the security that whatever
and I just think like how do you feel
good about spending that kind of money
on this kind of pomp and ceremony when
there are people that can't feed
themselves there's something really
wrong in the world when we're able to
kind of carve this off and that's what
we do all the time just kind of like
carve this off and you know look at
things in isolation one of the things
that I worry about in
you know a friend of mine we keep having
this conversation actually about our
failed bioethics and what does it mean
to do bioethics where you're looking at
ethical issues and to think about it in
terms of fiddling while Rome burns
really yeah you know and I think that's
one of the things I do worry about
whereas a day or se says it that we're
all drinking wine on the back of the
plane while the plane the pilot had a
heart attack in the planes crashing and
we're all just drinking wine and there's
one person looking out the window France
want to take control of the plane before
it crashes yeah so I think it's our
responsibility to get more people to
look out the window and go hey there's
something's wrong with the plane right
now let's let's make some changes but
you know what's really important it's a
good thing that you use the example of
the plane only because one things that
becomes really important is it has to be
possible for somebody who's looking out
the window to notice a problem and to
report it and for people to be willing
to trust and to act right I mean if you
think about it in those terms what are
all the arenas in which we don't pay
attention to the early warnings that
people are giving us because they don't
fit in the hierarchy of authority of
people who are able to name problems to
whom we have to respond or engage you
know I think that you know that's one of
the things that's really important
because in aviation safety you would pay
attention in theory to anybody who is a
passenger
they don't have to be you know anybody
with authority if a passenger said to
you like there's a problem here look
that you know the motor is gone people
would pay attention and the way in which
we live our lives we don't pay attention
to a lot of people that are trying to
warn us about promises and honestly
there I put that young generation know
they're telling us there's a problem
they're trying to when they complain
about what's happening to the
environment when they complain about the
capitalist structure which is harming
you know lots of people and not just
themselves overdosing on pharmaceuticals
yeah yeah for for anxiety and depression
associated with materialism and
Instagram followers and all that
[ __ ] all right how about we get at least
at least we touch on this just a little
bit on the way out the importance of
science communication yeah let's talk
about this because I think when we were
sitting down a little over an hour ago
we were talking about how there is
almost this this feeling of of being an
authority in the field when you know
something that other people don't know
and you can say to them in such a
complicated way where they don't get it
and that they have to refer to you and
then there's the role of people like you
and I that try and make what really
smart people say as a relatable as
possible to the public where they go I
can talk about that too that makes good
sense yeah I think that for me that's
one of the things that just drives my
work I'm deeply committed to what some
people call public education some people
call public engagement but I really talk
about it and think about it as public
empowerment I believe in democracy and I
believe in democracy having as one of it
sort of pillars an informed and engaged
public and I believe that people that
want to be informed should have access
to information and I think that I can
help to make that information available
and I wish more people would see that as
an important commitment but if you have
the talent and the ability to explain
things and ways that are accessible you
should be using get toned in that
ability and you should be encouraging
people to become engaged and to figure
out where their values sit in relation
to the world in which they're living and
I think for me what's really important
is what kind of world you want to live
in I spend a lot of time thinking about
the kind of world I want to live in but
the world I want to live in and there's
all these other people right
and so I want to help them to help me to
build a world that we will want to live
in and not the world that's just kind of
being created willy-nilly because
everybody's going about their day to day
thing not thinking about how all those
decisions cumulatively make up the world
that
even yesterday Matt Dillahunty was
saying that however you design the
future of civilization act as though you
don't know what piece of the puzzle you
will be so if you design it to have
slavery you don't know if you will be
the slave or the owner of the slave so
then you don't want slavery because of
that and it's the same thing kind of
with a person of are you educated enough
to be able to know how to vote and
contribute to the political system or
are you not because then we don't want
to have a system like that we want
everyone to be able to at least have a
basic understanding of what the
political and economic fabric is and
then to be able to make educated votes
within it because a lot of people are
trying to propose the system where if I
don't understand what's going on I can
delegate my vote to someone else and
then that someone else can vote maybe
for 200 people that have trusted them to
vote on their behalf because they have
the time they have the knowledge they
can do it for on behalf of us which is
so interesting that that is so
applicable to what you're talking about
public empowerment empowering people to
care more about the society that we live
in and building a better future and
caring more about science caring more
about about about our fellow humans
about humanism yeah
alright let's ask you a quick question
on the way out what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world
I'm tempted to go back to something that
we actually alluded to which is a
newborn baby because when you made that
comment earlier on you know what an
amazing thing it is that we can give
birth to this lovely next generation the
image that came to my mind when you said
that it's just the little ham right just
a lovely little hand that's grasping and
so I think it's pretty fun you know that
weight that we have this kind of ability
and that we don't actually just enjoy it
for what it is pretty amazing right
it's a very very beautiful life but it's
also at times we see a lot of suffering
and it's up to us to help and make it a
better world along the way but I think
that's that for me is the beauty because
you get to see this and to think what
kind of a world do you want them to
experience to inherit to contribute to
its said are so few if you think about
it in those terms and if you go back to
what I think I've been saying all along
that we are fundamentally relational
beings that person is going to become
part of the fabric of life and we ought
to be thinking about what that fabric
looks like yep exactly
hmm do you think we're alone in the
cosmos oh I'd be surprised if we were
don't you think it's a lot of hubris to
think that we're it yeah and do you
think this is base reality or a computer
simulation I have no idea I have no idea
do you think if an advanced civilization
exists out there I think an alternative
civilization because I sit there it's
like a really strange to think that
would be the only thing that's alive in
this huge huge cosmos um you when you
actually understand that we are ants
right like relative to the rest of you
know our level of understanding we know
that if it's being us and not just in
terms of size in relationship but in
terms of abilities and richness of life
we are ants to something else I'm pretty
confident of that
yeah we're ants even if you look from
the moon onto earth we're so a bunch of
ants there you go and we just sometimes
are a little bit too self-important
right but what else do we have what else
do we have so we think we're important
and you know it's a you have to come up
with your life as if this is it and this
is what's important but we are never to
forget that there's no reason to think
that we're the biggest best most
important thing anywhere in this cosmos
we're just something just something
Francois such a pleasure yeah it's a lot
of fun thank you for coming Wow thanks
for having me great we appreciate it I
know we can have this conversation again
give you a totally different show right
yes there was some other topic and just
kind of carry on we scratch the surface
on a couple different topics it was good
that we did that talked a lot about
sociology talked a lot about public
health
women's reproductive health talked about
building a better tighter social fabric
talked about so many different things
you actually referred to a lot of
philosophers without realizing it or
maybe you did realize that he just
didn't name them but I mean we've talked
about Rawls and the veil of ignorance we
have talked about the right to an open
future we have talked about all kinds of
interesting you know deep philosophical
ideas without having to handle at fancy
language right like but just working
with the ideas and the concepts and you
know that I think is what's wonderful
well then if you want people to
participate there's all kinds of ways of
saying the same thing right and that's
why we do it in the way that we do to
try and make it relatable digestible
ways that other people can grab on to it
and be like hey this is what I learned
this is what I was talking about this is
what I want to build with it now so
everyone thank you for tuning in we'd
greatly appreciate it if you guys had a
good time share the content with other
people come and below with your thoughts
build something with the content
subscribe join us like the content we
always say this but don't just consume
it go and create with it talk about it
write about it and make a video about it
do something with it build with it
thank you Ron vargas are producing
partner our director Thank You thanks
everyone for tuning in join us on
patreon to continue making the studio
space sustainable when you continue
growing this project and impacting more
people with it across the world so
please join us there and we'll catch you
guys soon thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]